[grand orchestral music]
- HELLO, MY FELLOW AMERICANS.
WITH ME, AS ALWAYS,
IS MY ANGER TRANSLATOR, LUTHER.
- HI!
- NOW, THE FIRST YEAR
OF MY SECOND TERM
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE.
- CLUSTER....[bleep]!
- TONIGHT, I'D LIKE
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
OVER WHAT THEY PERCEIVE
AS THE U.S. GOVERNMENT SPYING
ON THEIR DIGITAL
AND ELECTRONIC ACTIVITIES.
- MAN, Y'ALL SOME DELUDED,
SELF-IMPORTANT MOTHER[bleep]
IF YOU THINK WE INTERESTED
IN YOUR DEVIANT,
PORN-WATCHIN' ASSES!
- I CAN ASSURE YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
WE ARE NOT READING
EVERY INDIVIDUAL EMAIL.
RATHER, WE'RE SEARCHING
FOR KEY WORDS
THAT WOULD INDICATE A THREAT.
- AND DON'T WORRY,
EVERYBODY,
THOSE KEY WORDS ARE NOT
"GIRL ON GIRL,"
ANAL, SQUIRTING,
PLOPPING.
- HMM. "PLOPPING"?
- WHAT THE [bleep]
IS "PLOPPING,"
YOU DIRTY MOTHER[bleep]?
- THESE KEY WORDS
ARE BEING USED,
AMONGST OTHER THINGS,
TO PREVENT TERRORISTS
FROM USING WEAPONS
OF MASS DESTRUCTION.
- NOT PREVENT YOU
FROM WATCHING VIDEOS
OF ASS DESTRUCTION!
- NOW, THESE POLICIES
HAVE ALREADY FOILED
NUMEROUS TERRORIST PLOTS.
- THESE ARE NOT THE KIND OF
PLOTS THAT Y'ALL ARE USED TO,
LIKE WHEN A GUY
COMES IN THE DOOR
WITH HIS PENIS
IN A PIZZA BOX,
AND LADY SUCKS ON IT.
- AND I ASSURE YOU
THAT THE COUNTRY'S
GOTTEN SAFER
SINCE THE END
OF THE BUSH ERA.
- AND I AIN'T TALKIN'
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT. BOOP.
- THESE POLICIES HAVE ALLOWED US
TO PROBE AND PENETRATE...
- I KNOW Y'ALL BEEN PROBIN--
- UNTIL THE DE--NO, LUTHER...
JUST, WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY IS
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN NUMEROUS
TERRORIST CELLS FINGERED--
- AND YOU GOT FINGERS, YOU PUT--
- AND THAT--LUTHER.
- OKAY. LUTHER,
WHY ARE YOU TRYING
TO UNDERMINE THE PRESIDENT
WITH YOUR JUVENILE
SEXUAL INNUENDO?
- THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
HAS NOTHING TO FEAR
FROM THESE POLICIES.
- NOW! IF WE WAS
DRONE-STRIKIN' PERVERTS,
OUR COUNTRY WOULD LOOK LIKE
MAD MAX: BEYOND THUNDERDOME
RIGHT ABOUT NOW.
I'M TALKIN' ABOUT
A POST-APOCALYPTIC NIGHTMARE!
- THANK YOU,
AND GOOD NIGHT.
- GO TO SLEEP, Y'ALL.
- "PLOPPING"?
- OH, YES, SIR.
THAT'S WHEN...
- OH!
Y'ALL ARE SOME SICK
MOTHER[bleep].